good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight workers of the world
unite you have nothing to lose but your
chains that's from karl marx of course
he wrote that famous phrase in 1848. the
weird thing is it's pretty likely that
marx himself never met an actual worker
wait a second he didn't spend a decade
in a cotton mill witnessing the
oppression firsthand no
karl marx never spent a moment in a
factory he was a rich kid who became a
journalist of course he was
but for more than 150 years karl marx
inspired generations of other rich kids
who also became journalists to repeat
his learner variations of it
over time workers became working men or
working class and then with feminism
working people or working families
but the idea itself never changed
ordinary people wage earners are getting
shafted so they've got to unite they've
got to come together for protection and
for dignity this was the idea of course
behind the organized labor movement and
every democratic president from andrew
jackson until now has made the very same
point over and over again the noble
people of scranton you hear it even
today
so democrats have repeated that line
often enough you would think they really
mean it do they really mean it let's
take the test here's how you know
watch what happens when actual workers
working people from working families who
constitute the working class actually
come together as a group to protest how
things are going what happens then
does the intellectual class greet these
workers as heroes
throw a parade listen intently to their
stories does npr do a sympathetic
feature on them
or
do self-described progressives recoil in
revulsion and horror at the grubbiness
of the people who as we used to say work
for a living do liberals immediately
denounce them as nazis and call for
their suppression by force that's the
question
what's the answer we'll ask trump voters
what happens they'll know
or consider what's happening right now
in canada thousands of truck drivers
have descended on ottawa the capital
city to protest the tyranny of justin
trudeau's government justin trudeau does
not like truck drivers he thinks they're
revolting justin trudeau likes private
equity barons and tech moguls and other
people who give him money trudeau is not
in ottawa right now in fact he and his
family fled when the trunk drivers
arrived and they've been in hiding ever
since so when the revolution he has been
calling for finally arrived justin
trudeau wasn't there to see it he ran
away in terror kind of sad
so instead in his place his friend mark
carney has been speaking for him carney
is a former goldman sachs executive who
many believe will replace justin trudeau
if trudeau ever decides to give up power
in a recent op-ed mark carney vented his
rage at the impudent truckers in ottawa
and anyone who sent the money on the
internet quote anyone sending money to
the convoy should be in no doubt carney
wrote you are funding sedition
foreign funders of an insurrection
interfered in our domestic affairs from
the start
got that it's not a protest it's
sedition it's an insurrection
clearly mark carney's been watching a
lot of cnn up there in canada and that's
why he's concluded that truckers should
be crushed by force quote
those who are still helping to extend
this occupation must be identified and
punished to the full force of the law
people who sent the money should be
prosecuted
if they're not prosecuted mark carney
fears quote the constant blaring of
horns at all hours will bankrupt our
businesses
are you laughing yet
so the very same finance ghouls
who cheered lockdowns for two solid
years are now deeply concerned that
small businesses might be hurt by the
trucker protests
hilarious
it'd be interesting by the way to poll
small business owners in ottawa to see
what they think how do they feel about
the truckers somehow you know exactly
what those results would be but no one's
doing that poll of course
instead they found an easier way justin
trudeau has just ordered police to shut
the whole thing down how do you do that
how do you stop a truck protest simple
you seize their fuel that's exactly what
police in canada are doing watch
numbers
so in fact yes
they are taking fuel right away from
people
as they attempt
to fuel their vehicles
okay so we are through much practice
connoisseurs of irony so let's pause a
moment to savor the irony here the very
same people who told us we had to defund
the police are now telling the police to
seize fuel from working-class canadians
who are trying to stay alive in arctic
temperatures
as they used to say in the 1960s scratch
a liberal and you will find a fascist
that was a black panther slogan actually
they weren't entirely stupid in fact in
this case they were absolutely right
according to justin trudeau possessing
gasoline in the city of ottawa is now a
crime
now to be clear ottawa didn't declare
the state of emergency because the
truckers lit a courthouse on fire or
shot someone or leveled a church blm did
all of those things but justin trudeau
strongly supports blm he reaffirmed his
support the other day
here's the problem and we're going to
let the mayor of ottawa or atawa as it's
correctly pronounced ojibwa
explain why peaceful truck drivers pose
an imminent danger to canada
it's disturbing when you see the the
protest turning into what looks like
some kind of a fun carnival where
they've got bouncy castles and hot tubs
and saunas a complete uh
insult to the people who are putting up
with this nonsense for the last seven
days and it shows a great deal of
instant insensitivity
they've got bouncy castles for kids
growl's the childless mayor of ottawa
let's hurt them
yes ladies and gentlemen it's a dark
scene in trukastan tonight the kids are
on the bouncy castles
of course at the same time their parents
are flaunting the authority of the
people in charge and that is the crime
watch this protester a white supremacist
explain his motives for protest
where the hell were you you weren't
there absolutely but now you want to
come out in the freezing cold to oppose
my fundamental human rights and freedoms
i'm not gonna have it i'm blackman
standing beside my brother right here
this is my brother that's right right
here and none of you have the right to
tell me who to associate with and who
not to associate with me because you did
not come out and voice your concerns for
the fact that justin trudeau banned me
from leaving this country because of my
medical decision because i made a
decision that he did not like
shut up racist go back to jamaica with
your white supremacy nonsense
by the way no one in canada's government
or the media in canada which is mostly
controlled by the government is engaging
with any of the arguments of people like
that instead they've gone directly to
force as crumbling regimes always do
they don't have an argument to make all
they have is police power and they're
using them officials in ottawa has
threatened to criminally investigate the
california company gofundme because
truckers raised about 10 million dollars
on the platform here's ottawa's police
chief bragging about stealing that money
we have through the efforts of deputy
bell christian hino
uh the mayor and his staff we've been
able to shut down the go funding program
that's a temporary reprieve because the
funds are already moving in different
directions
we are now going after supply and fuel
coming into the area through
investigations and intelligence
operations and interdictions all of
which were underway yesterday fully
underway today
intelligence operations
this is a peaceful political protest no
one has shown any evidence to the
contrary it's not a drug trafficking or
human trafficking operation it's not al
qaeda these are canadian citizens you
drive trucks for a living
but they're being treated like a terror
group
gofundme announced it would redirect the
10 million dollars raised by supporters
of the truckers to charities of its
choice presumably blm which it has
supported since the very beginning in
other words gofundme plan to steal that
money
they were stopped from doing this by the
way by a number of american attorneys
general who threatened to sue the
company so the company backed off and
they're going to refund the money
supposedly but still the truckers the
people for whom this money was intended
will not get it
so in the absence of gofundme doing what
it's supposed to do
others are filling the gap an
alternative crowdfunding website called
give send go has stepped up and raised
already more than five million dollars
for the truckers how long until they try
to shut that down too
some canadians are clearly worried about
that they're turning to cryptocurrency
tallycoin for example is a small
crowdfunding service that uses bitcoin
it's not controlled by banks that's the
point
they're hosting a fundraiser for the
truckers now why is this appealing no
one can steal the money no government
can pressure anyone to turn the money
over because governments don't control
crypto
bitcoin goes from person a to person b
and all the intermediary does the
company is connect the two it's pretty
appealing and you can imagine the
long-term consequences here if the
people in charge in this country and in
canada want to make the us dollar
irrelevant they'll keep acting like this
and soon that it will be
either way it's becoming very clear that
the only way around
the stranglehold the technology has on
our human rights is decentralization
that doesn't apply just to crowdfunding
but more than anything to communication
you can't organize if you can't talk to
other people so facebook for example to
shut down the convoy to dc group which
should amass 134 thousand followers in
just two days no one's allowed to
promote the organization anymore
facebook all day today has been
suppressing positive articles about the
truckers in canada of course they are
that seems like a story but our media
have ignored it instead everyone in new
york and dc in los angeles is cheering
on the national security state and its
alliance with silicon valley as they
come together to crush a human rights
movement makes sense those with the
so-called freedom convoy say they're
staying put until vaccine mandates are
dropped
the masks come off and life returns to
the way it was
this whole event has gone beyond just
vaccines and it is now about the entire
ordeal we're asking for our freedom
that's all we want so they've been free
free to park big rigs right next to the
prime minister's office free to set up
camp in front of the country's national
parliament ottawa police say they have
learned much in the past week especially
after reports of assaults intimidation
and allegations of hate speech and
symbols this remains as it was from the
beginning
an increasingly volatile and
increasingly dangerous demonstration and
it is spreading like a contagion itself
right across the country
it's spreading like a contagion now you
knew that cnn was the praetorian guard
for our ruling class did you know they
serve the same role in canada and what
other countries how much money does cnn
take from the government of canada
that'd be worth finding out
they described what's happening in
ottawa as they quote violent and
dangerous demonstration really where's
the violence coming from the only people
getting injured or have been injured so
far are the protesters the truckers in
winnipeg on friday an anarchist called
david zegerak drove his jeep into four
people who are protesting vax mandates
you're seeing that on the screen right
now zegorak didn't stop after hitting
the people he fled police really
arrested him
of course police are treating the
incident like a hit and run nothing
political it's not domestic terrorism or
anything david zegerak has views they
agree with he's a progressive a true
believer
how much is he a true believer if you
look closely you'll notice that zegerak
has his mask on driving alone in his car
during the assault
prima facie evidence of mental illness
something you see in this country all
the time and it makes you wonder if
you're driving alone with a mask on
do you pose a danger to pedestrians
entirely possible someone should fund a
study on that
that seems like a big story especially
since it's happening just an hour from
our own border all of this the question
is how long before protests like this
come here
clearly our media are worried about that
watch the morning news anchors on msnbc
they're deeply deeply concerned about
these uppity working class people watch
where were these protests when people
were required to give their children
five vaccines they were in the doctor's
office getting vaccines they were in the
doctor's office getting vaccinated they
were making fun of left-wingers on the
west coast for being loopy
anti-vaxxers
now they have met the enemy and the
enemy
their enemy
is themselves because they've become
what they hated it's
a
cult
so here you have joe and mika sneering
from their studio in florida at the
freezing wage earners stuck outside in
ottawa in february because they want
their human rights screw them
would joe scarborough say that to their
faces
probably not scarborough is famously
tough on young female employees some say
he's an absolute killer in the office
but it's hard to imagine scarborough
talking like this if there was an actual
canadian trucker in the room
truckers in this country are watching
all of this and you wonder what do they
think about it
what would happen if american truck
drivers decide they'd had enough of
people like joe scarborough and went on
strike what would happen then
well this country would stop immediately
no more deliveries of anything over time
that would mean starvation for people in
the cities
but even in the short term there would
be profound suffering in this country
for example and this is something that
too few people outside of television
even consider
the world's entire supply of botox is
manufactured on the west coast of
ireland that's a long way from here in
fact it's a 4 000 mile long supply chain
from the allergan plant in westport
ireland to jupiter florida
now people at msnbc might not be aware
of this but our country has no domestic
botox production along with vitamin c
and antibiotics it's one of the
life-saving pharmaceutical products we
have recklessly offshored
so if the trucks stop delivering the
botox stops coming and suddenly your
morning television anchors are going to
look like they're 58 years old which
actually they are
could that happen is it impossible no
it's not impossible
the people in charge aren't really
thinking this through
most of the time trends started the
united states and they moved north to
canada but this time the opposite could
happen